to move that gotta do even as it's a
couple years ago you know I would be
told specifically if I certain club
owners don't play that
and now those are the same club owners
that are booking fideo party so I get
home parties so it's like well what
happened right like what changed hey
guys it's Sunnah I'm in New York City
exploring the roots of one of the most
popular musical genres today and its
journey from being an expression of
afro-caribbean identity to well
everywhere
[Music]
you definitely know the reggaeton sound
baby when you talk
[Music]
oh you know one Shula you love was
handmade for somebody like me while
those songs aren't reggaeton they do use
that very unique rhythm known as Dembo
and Wayne Marshall a music historian can
break that rhythm down if you've ever
heard reggaeton you've probably heard
that running underneath you could say
somewhere between 3/4 to 100% of all
tracks contain these actual sounds a
really good and popular example of a
reggaeton song that uses these sounds
instead a Yankees 2004 hit gasoline oh
[Music]
so what are the roots of that rhythm
reggaeton is deeply diasporic music and
in the number of different ways all of
this would not happen if it wasn't for
Jamaica like straight up I always say
passage way from Jamaica to the
immigrants that I went to Panama to
build a canal which is part of my
personal lineage reggaeton has this
history of being born out of like the
way that people are playing in the clubs
like in Porto Rico for example of taking
hiphop samples hip hop loops dancehall
loops from the original records the
early origins of reggaeton actually go
back to the emergence of dancehall
reggae in the late 80s and early 90s in
Jamaica
it started in literal dance halls where
the selectors or DJs would mess around
with a sound by using the volume knob to
let in as much of the rhythm as they
wanted creating what Marshall calls up
poly ripping and then artists actually
started building this effect into their
own tracks and it sounded like this so
that's an example of what started to
become a sort of prevailing pattern in
dancehall reggae the most influential of
these tracks of course is Shabba Ranks
Dembo and the original four Dembo sounds
like this you'll note that it uses the
same snare drum rhythms that we just
heard on Pokemon Jenna
in Panama artists like n henares started
remaking dancehall reggae hits
translating them to Spanish this became
known as it I can espanol and DJ Nelson
a pioneer in reggaeton explains why the
use of Spanish by those Panamanian
artists was important for him in Puerto
Rico years ago oh my god these guys are
singing in Spanish I can't understand
imagined artists from Puerto Rico
singing in Spanish on a hip upbeat dance
of the house beats techno beats it's
crazy ok so back to Panama many of the
artists making organa Spaniel songs were
the descendants of immigrants from
Jamaica and the West Indies who had
moved to Panama in the early 20th
century to work on the Panama Canal and
they wanted to keep in touch with their
roots couple generations later they
still had familial and cultural ties to
Jamaica reggae was one of many regional
musics that were part of the sort of
popular mix it was in New York the
Panamanian artists like el henna doll
actually recorded in Jamaican recording
studios and a lot of reggaeton history
and development happened here because
it's here where panamanians Jamaicans
Puerto Ricans and African Americans
across communities and sounds those
communities in New York's hip-hop scene
were instrumental in the development of
reggaeton as Petra Rivera Widow who
studies race and pop culture explains if
you talk to early reggaeton artists you
know many of them list hip-hop artists
in the US as some of their biggest
influences in new york puerto rican
settled everywhere but among the
neighborhoods that were where there was
a largest concentration was the bronx
the south bronx and this is where hip
hop originated and that hip hop sound
traveled from New York to San Juan while
a lot of people consider Puerto Rico to
be the home of reggaeton the question of
who owns it is actually a lot more
complicated because the history of
reggaeton is the history of diasporas
and migration the noise was one of the
most influential collectives to come out
of Puerto Rico in the 90s
we actually came to the Red Bull Music
Festival you can totally hear the
reggaeton playing in the background and
we caught up with DJ Negril and DJ
Nelson of the noise
con la musica also because in sauna I'll
rally a coca meanza el hierro l- in
porto rico on the way around before the
noise became a musical collective it was
actually a club in San Juan and it's
where artists like daddy yankee and Evie
Queen got her start the noise as a club
was founded in 1991 by DJ Negro whoa yo
girl at eco de Cali no his cousin were
without only osika fame I don't know
using a while there we are seldom
potentiated on Bali I don't know my
daddy Cocalico take a parent to say
sorry la la gente que me Suginami como
DJ firmeza momento nouvion reggaeton aro
scientist a Yahoo Napolitano movie at
the same time the noise was pretty much
the only place where you could listen to
music that later became known as
reggaeton that's because underground as
it was known then wasn't really widely
light and it was associated with
criminality and obscenity do you know
how asses looking about girls talking
about Casa Rio's talking about crazy
things you take the country by surprise
era era mo lo peor de lo peor
hey don't hang out okay no exist here no
father in okarian Colosio couch Alana
travels iike a ecommerce site to lady
sat on a couch abroad a Hondo doodle I
will tell our culture this is where are
the parallels between hip hop in the 90s
and reggaeton in the 90s get really
interesting the way hip hop came from
New York's projects underground music
proto reggaeton was coming out of
Cassidy oz or public housing
developments in San Juan and just like
the projects in New York or really
anywhere in the United States
Cassidy O's were associated not only
with the working class but with
blackness and while a good part of
Puerto Ricans are believed to have
African and indigenous ancestry the Afro
Porto Rican community has a history of
being stigmatized I mean check this in
the 90s in particular black Americans
were stigmatized on the mainland through
associations made between their
communities the project's drug use
increased so-called urban
and obscene music and so were afro
Puerto Ricans in Puerto Rico it's not
necessarily true that Cassidy Oz were
the epicenter of criminal activity but
they developed a reputation as being a
place where a lot of criminal activity
particularly around drugs was taking
place between 1993 and 1996 the Puerto
Rican government actually launched a
campaign called mano doodle contra
agreement or the iron fist against crime
and targeted casinos in particular they
used the National Guard and the Puerto
Rican police to kind of occupy the COS
videos as a way to curb violent crime
and it was a pretty violent occupation
at the same time mano Duda what's
happening the government also undertook
a censorship campaign the police came
out to the stores and get the tapes the
cassettes people listening to the
reggaeton in the cars get stopped by the
police he was crazy times momento de lo
que el que toman como lo Paola Malo no
Eden s okay and then in 2002 there was
another censorship campaign and it was
focused on pornography largely targeting
reggaeton music videos but because
Puerto Rico is a u.s. territory the
Constitution protected free speech
prevailed but that didn't stop the
stigma that was associated with the
music and that in turn encouraged
artists to explore their own realities
more so in their music popular music and
Puerto Rico has been a space where
people have contested a lot of these
racial ideologies and pointed out racial
discrimination tygo Calderon has several
songs where he directly calls out this
idea of racial harmony as a myth where
he talks about institutional
discrimination facing black Puerto
Ricans in an explicit kind of way
I wanna point out that even though
reggaeton has this reputation of hyper
sexualizing women women singers and
rappers were actually part of the scene
from really early on
take for example Evie queen who was part
of the noise and today you have women
like DJ Ben Bona Gigi Rio Bamba who are
changing the reggaeton scene and image
like we love Tyrell even when you throw
some tracks in you're like maybe I
shouldn't be playing this right now but
I just love to throw my ass back I play
those tracks as I'm gonna stand in front
of it and be like I'm not supposed to be
here like I'm not supposed to take up
this space but like I'm gonna reclaim
that space in the club and the way that
like this was never intended to be and
then there's also the question of the
whitewashing of reggaeton too much I
think a big reason that I kept on has
had this huge crossover dynamo market
moment is that it's become whitewash it
does erase the roots of the genre and it
doesn't race a lot of artists that have
been there since the beginning that are
like equally if not more talented and
amazing that I've never had this moment
but the history of the genre is a
history of diaspora communities
connected through their afro Caribbean
heritage trying to reclaim it I am
mindful Athena I am black and I'm proud
I'm Panamanian Puerto Rican of all these
things together
no more assimilation none of that like
we have to take up the space that you
know the generations before us weren't
able to hey guys thanks for watching
hope you enjoyed the video let us know
what are some other pop culture
histories that you want us to delve into
and hopefully we'll get around to it
don't forget to Like share and subscribe